now that I have the coordinates of the
focus and the equation of the director
okay I can use that to try and get
something about the X interest in your
relationship now last time we got this
relationship okay now I just said a
whole bunch of this stuff is the same
okay so some logic would say we're
probably going to get the same
relationship how could you tell how
could you tell if it was the same if
it's not then what is it
do you remember how we did it how do we
how do we get the treasure when did we
went back to the definition of what this
thing is
right we said it's a PS that's a
distance formula that's a perpendicular
distance formula good you can do it take
your 90 seconds flat
did you get there sorry I'm in a bit of
a hurry did you get that
now what's he's the puppets interesting
to me what did you have here underneath
why swim if you teach your algebra right
that's what you should land on okay
which is like ooh hold on so much of
this was the same what went different
what is different what see how different
is this to the ellipse that we looked at
before
think about what we started with look at
look at these pieces they were all the
same
okay so once you've got in here see to
make this an ellipse you'd say well I
need a plus there but if you get rid of
one minus sign it's got to go somewhere
so the most natural place is where this
is so that switches around like so okay
so therefore if we actually do want to
stay with a boat you - there but this is
something which I think is easy to screw
up okay this is this is a trouble I had
if you've learned this for ellipses but
I had purple or it's the other way
around
all right now you did a good job getting
the focus that was finding the directrix
fine eccentricity we can work out using
this relationship here namely that's B
squared isn't it right so therefore for
hyperbolic weird like this a square e
squared minus 1 so we can work out the
eccentricity for this guy if they're not
into let's do it here this way is 9
equals 25 squared
okay 25 add one gives you one never come
34 125 yeah
so II we're taking the positive value
because the ratios so it's a square root
of 34 on five we do okay now we haven't
answered the question what are a and B
what significance do they have to do the
hyperbola okay
we're pretty close with this we already
got this distance right
so we noted that that was what's it
equal to just too angry right I'm not
much good to call the major axis but
because two completely different
geometric shape so they give it a
different name this is not called the
major axis they call it because it's
going across between the two branches
they call it the transverse axis because
it is still an axis of symmetry that
distance there from A to B across now
what's the other piece where's B well I
already mentioned right that B has to do
with at least here it had to do with
your burning or squishing and squashing
or stretching or whatever okay it's
doing exactly the same thing here it's
just that it doesn't do it on actual
points which is a little weird I know
but it's still referring to a distance
similar to this but it's vertical okay
so it's gonna be a distance of like at
this now in this case what do we have
sorry this is just a made-up wizard so
if I had nine okay I had some points
plus or minus three right and that
distance between them I guess that would
be Sikhs also gets given their name it's
called the conjugate axis
okay in some words conjugant accesses
access is kind of like a like what its
conjugate me we know it just means the
other one doesn't it right
it's like root 3 + 2 + root 3 minus or a
plus bi and a minus bi it's just the
other matching one right so I kind of
view it as it's the other axis you know
this is the important one however we do
get a very important phrase from this ok
let's take this idea on 25 on 9 if I
don't you switch them right
literally swap them around I'm swapping
the transverse axis and the conjugate
axis so we give that name I'll give you
an example with this particular one I
gave you before if I said x squared on 9
Y squared of 25 okay these guys are
related to each other then the same
thing but they rotated no sorry not
rotated their proportions are in Reverse
ok so we call it the conjugate axis I'm
sorry the clutch get hype / ok
why that should be X so in fact what
you're going to get is because when you
switch X&Y what kind of geometric
difference to you like what's the
difference in this guy and this guy it's
90 degrees isn't it right
so therefore what you get when you
rotate this 90 degrees is these guys
let's see that now the important thing
because of the way they're in ratios
work I'm gonna double check this in a
second just make sure I got away is that
these quadriga hyperbola hyperbole they
share the same asymptote so you can
almost even see it there if I drew it
properly so they have this special
relationship to each other all right one
more special term to give to you while
I'm talking about all these different
weird names and that is one which is
sort of familiar because we've been
drawing it for a long time what do you
think about this guy right he's a bit
different isn't here because he's not it
doesn't have symmetry across the axis
like that or search across these axes
he's off at an angle okay but the
important thing about him is okay just
like these hyperbola right there are
asymptotes what are the asymptotes in
this case there and y equals zero okay
now we've kind of been working this guy
and assuming him for a long time but
he's special because these absent turns
are perpendicular to each other you know
the very first one I gave you
what would the asymptotes you remember
they were it was like root 3x minus root
3 there's something there about they're
not meeting at right angles okay so if I
have the media right angles we call this
one and any variation of that kind so
long as the asymptotes
we call it the rectangular because you
know a rectangle is the shape that has
right angles it okay yeah he's a he's a
toss for you to go and have a think
about what's the exit is just you this
thing every rectangular hyperbola
as a Sam eccentricity do you believe me
but but what is it and how do you show
it you can you can get the edges very
nice neat number why is that one day
we'll have the same one any which way
you turn if it's those